[Music]
[Music]
good morning
it's seven o'clock you're watching the
only breakfast show live from
westminster and today
israeli-palestinian violence escalates
with rockets fired at the tourist
capital of tel aviv
and street clashes in one israeli town
so
how will world leaders respond well the
environment secretary
george eustis is on the program shortly
plus we'll bring the very latest gdp
figures this hour and talk to the shadow
business secretary
ed miliband about the uk's economic
outlook
also for you this morning cool runnings
the inside story of how the biggest
names in track cycling were beaten by a
team of amateurs
all thanks to reverse engineering
and as part of mental health awareness
week love island star jack fincham will
be with us
to talk about the pressures that some
men face to get that so-called
perfect appearance it is wednesday
the 12th of may
rockets over tel aviv the israeli prime
minister says
hamas will pay a heavy price following
an attack on
israel's tourist capital israel steps up
its airstrikes on gaza where 35
palestinians including
10 children have been killed we speak to
the israeli defense force
it seems that what israel is doing in
guards at gaza is totally
disproportionate to what is happening
here i would
beg to differ i think that what we are
doing are specific
strikes against military targets
covid hot spots sky news reveals the
dozens of areas facing
increasing coronavirus infection rates
as local leaders
call for emergency vaccinations
struck by lightning a nine-year-old boy
dies after apparently being hit by
lightning in a football
field in blackpool
police continue a search in gloucester
after claims a teenager
feared to have been murdered by fred
west could be buried there
we'll talk to rose west's former lawyer
[Applause]
[Music]
and back in business the brit awards
sees the return of live events with no
social distancing for fans
in what turned out to be a big night for
female artists
and the weather stays rather mixed over
the next few days on the one hand we
need the rainfall
on the other we like the sunshine to
find out what the day has in store
join me for the weather details later in
the programme
a very good morning to you we start with
the escalating tensions in israel with
rockets
fired and intercepted by defense systems
at the tourist capital tel aviv and
street clashes in one israeli town
between arab israelis and
israeli police well overnight hamas
militants launched a rocket attack on
the capital city of tel aviv
five people have died in israel prime
minister binyamin netanyahu says hamas
will pay
a heavy price israel meanwhile has
stepped up its airstrikes on gaza where
35 palestinians have been killed
including 10 children for the scale of
the hamas attack on tel aviv
appears to be unprecedented aimed at
penetrating israel's high-tech
iron dome system mark stone reports now
from ashkelon in israel subject to
another attack
earlier in the day
overnight in tel aviv images that change
everything in an escalation that has
already spiraled so
fast israel's missile defense systems
lighting up the sky as they try to
intercept
incoming hamas rockets 130 of them were
fired from gaza in one barrage
flights at the international airport
were urgently suspended and diverted
hamas said it was a specific target
and on the streets injured israelis
which for israel
will move this conflict onto a different
level
the earlier israeli assault on gaza
which prompted the hamas retaliation
had been relentless and for those who
are not the targets
but who are so often the victims it is
terrifying
with the weight of the israeli air force
on top of them there is
nowhere safe to run
locals filmed the moment a 13-story
building collapsed
it's not clear how many people were in
it at the time it is a residential block
the israelis had earlier said that they
were targeting militants in their
homes the number confirmed to have died
through the day
and the night before continues to rise
children too
here a mother and her son are buried
they're from a refugee camp
most in gaza are refugees and in one of
the hospitals
agony and defiance this man vows revenge
for the death of his comrade
a member of hamas's jerusalem brigade
on the israeli side of the fence which
locks gaza off
in the city of ashkelon the air raid
sirens sounded through the day
in the skies the trails of israel's iron
dome missile defense system
it shot down most of the hamas rockets
the israeli communities here are used to
attacks from gaza
but not this many in just a few hours
this is the third time it's happened
since we've been here uh
you hear the whale and the sirens and
then moments later
sometimes the thud of the rockets as
they they come in
from gaza there have been scores of
rockets over the course of the past few
hours most of them
hitting here around this town a
wade the home of an elderly lady and her
carer they both died
unable to get to the shelter in time the
israeli defense forces spokesman was
here
keen to show us what israel faces from
hamas
no one can look at this and and see
anything other than a tragedy
that has happened here but the images
that are coming out of gaza are truly
horrific
it seems that what israel is doing in
gaza is totally disproportionate to what
is happening here
i would beg to differ i think that what
we are doing are specific
strikes against military targets inside
gaza that are part of the
hamas and the islamic jihad's military
infrastructure
and on top of all this another deeply
worrying development
overnight serious clashes between
israeli jews and israeli arabs in towns
within israel
a new active fracture
let's go in let's go in through the
night the rockets continued
hamas claims to be the defender of the
palestinian cause striking their
occupier
israel will strike back harder still and
the diplomacy to break this cycle
isn't there mark stone sky news in
southern israel
well let's talk to our foreign affairs
editor deborah haynes who's in jerusalem
for us this morning and clearly this
attack on tel aviv
is a severe escalation
well an escalation that has prompted um
from the israeli side significant air
strikes
into gaza up until this morning
the israelis saying that they have been
going after intelligence
intelligence officials the the homes of
hamas
leaders rocket launch sites but
obviously it's a densely populated area
and as we're seeing the um the the
health officials in gaza saying
civilians are being targeted and killed
um the israelis say that a thou more
than a thousand rockets have been
launched towards israel
since monday most of them intercepted
but but some of them falling into israel
and about 200
falling short into gaza and as mark
alluded to in his peace there are also
frictions here in israel with cities
with arab israeli populations
unrest growing there a state of
emergency called
caused it called in one city of lord
okay deborah thank you well we're joined
in the studio by the environment
secretary
george eustis good to see you this
morning look can i ask first and
foremost for
a reaction to what we're seeing in
israel because clearly this is now
escalating at some pace yes look it's
very concerning it's clearly a very
uh febrile atmosphere there at the
moment uh these rocket attack
attacks are taking place right you know
from gaza into israel
obviously completely unacceptable we've
really got to know de-escalate things
and i think the foreign secretary will
be saying a bit more about this later
today i'm sure that he's uh in touch
including
endorsing and trying to get all of those
involved you know to de-escalate and
calm this situation
i mean of course uh with tel aviv being
attacked
um israel's only recently gone on the
green list there's no
official change in advice for traveling
to israel at the moment on the on the
fco website is is that going to change
well look the fco keep all of this uh
under review
both for you know security and safety
reasons
but also then the department for health
also and the department for transport
have those lists linked to the pandemic
so there are different reasons why the
foreign office might
change their advice but they do review
it regularly um
can i ask you about one thing which is
causing a lot of concern at the moment
and that are these covered hot spots
which
which we've discovered and certainly in
22
local areas there seems to have been a
dramatic rise
actually in in the number of of covert
infections taking place how concerned
are you
that this is happening well we do
monitor this closely so we
we're doing a lot of lateral flow
testing now surveillance testing
both in schools with regular testing at
home
but also now in workplaces and that does
enable us to
pick up these hot spots we're not quite
sure what could be
driving it whether it's a particular
variants that are taking hold there
whether it's that
in certain areas people are perhaps
being a bit too lacks about the
restrictions that remain in place
um so we're unclear about that but we
are monitoring these um situations
carefully but overall the picture is a
good one where we've got
falling incidents of the virus and
obviously
with the success of the vaccine rollout
as well far fewer
hospitalizations and deaths now at a
very low level
i mean there is concern that some of
this may be linked to some variants
coming in which raises concerns is that
you need to
to to sort of stamp on this quickly to
stop it having a wider impact in the
country so with that in mind
what do you make of i mean some local
leaders calling for
emergency vaccination programs in these
limited areas
could that be looked at well we've
generally taken the view that because
we've got
capacity in place right across the
country we should just keep moving
through
those cohorts in uh in age order so
we're just moving down through the age
ranges
once you start bringing in uh
complications it gets more difficult to
uh to to deliver uh makes it more
complicated and potentially means you
you slow down the overall vaccination
program so the recommendation from the
the joint committee
uh on vaccinations is that we should
just keep moving down through the age
ranges and that's what we've been doing
quite successfully what about the
possibility of regional restrictions
then or even sort of tighter
local restrictions on some areas where
where we are seeing this increase
well we can't rule anything out but uh
you know our plan that's been uh set out
by the prime minister the reason we're
being incredibly cautious about exiting
lockdown is
we want this to be the last we want to
try and avoid having to get into
a tiered system and regionalization we
tried that last autumn we know
uh you know we know that in the end we
had to go for a full lockdown
we've got our confidence now in the
vaccination program
that's rolling out that is uh delivering
uh it is also reducing transmission
rates as well as uh reducing
uh hospitalizations and mortality and so
that's got to be
our focus but there is always a risk and
the greatest risk probably have is that
a new variant
that will come in that is uh the vaccine
is less effective against and that's why
we're a country that's got the best
ability in the world to do genome
sequencing on these new variants
wherever they might be
is it fair to say though that nothing is
off the table at this stage because
so the tremendous progress that has been
made and the road map
still in place at the moment i mean you
simply can't afford for that to start
going backwards can you
no and it's why we've been so cautious
at
exiting the lockdown taking things
carefully one stage at a time
prime minister you know now announcing
what we're going to do on may the 17th
and we just have to basically take each
step at a time
look at the impacts of that so far the
easements in restrictions that we've
made have been a success they haven't
led to
an increase in infection things have
still continued to go in the right
direction so we've got the confidence to
move to that next level
but it does i think show that you know
there are there are always risks here
which is why we should be cautious about
the way we go about this uh look
we hear there's going to be some word on
on the public inquiry into how the covet
pandemic has been handled
were expecting that announcement today
are we
well look there's um there will be a
time and a place i think for
an inquiry of that sort i'm not aware
that anything's being announced today on
it
you know for now um we're not out of
this yet uh we've still got
a huge amount to do obviously it's been
a very
traumatic episode for the whole world
and it's undoubtedly the case that
everybody will want to
learn lessons from it uh it's been such
a big event
but for now we've still got to focus on
getting ourselves
out of this situation we've made some
great progress with the
vaccine program but we've got to keep
our focus on that can i ask you about
the valley murphy 10
the inquest yesterday uh found that they
were
entirely innocent i mean this obviously
dating back to 1971.
but do we need to see some official
apology being made now well look we've
only just
obviously had this judgment uh from the
coroner
um i'm sure that brandon lewis in the
northern ireland office and others in
government will be
looking at this uh closely and then
we'll you know we'll give a
give a response to it uh but you know
these the troubles were
an incredibly difficult episode uh in
our country's history
we have now had some of these uh
inquiries this latest one i think
started almost a decade ago and has just
concluded
uh but i'm sure that we'll be looking at
that carefully before responding to it
i mean it's interesting though looking
at david cameron when there was the
bloody sunday inquiry he said you do not
defend the british army by defending the
individual
of course and um you know um that's
still that does still
that does still stand i mean it's why at
the same time um an inquiry the
coroner's
inquest started on this particular
incident yeah but i mean
when when this ruling has been made
that these were 10 innocent people
surely that
there can't be a a great deal that needs
to be considered before an apology is
made on the basis that
you know it could actually make
significant inroads
into healing some of this couldn't it
well look i haven't seen the uh the full
inquest uh report yet it's only just
been published
uh you know and if i'm not going to
preempt it's obviously the
responsibility of brandon lewis and the
northern ireland office to
look at these matters i'm sure they'll
be studying this closely before
responding to it so i i can't say any
more than that at this stage
um can i talk about animal welfare
because i know you're you're involved in
in this new move that the the uk is
making about protecting animals in the
uk and abroad actually
which is applying um not only to pets
but to livestock
how does this work uh well there's a
very wide range of um announcements that
we have in this document we're
publishing today
when it comes to livestock we had a
manifested commitment to ban
the live export of animals we will be
bringing forward legislation to deliver
that
we're also looking at issues such as
transport
journey times and so on on livestock
and and also looking at things like
slaughterhouse regulations so it's a
very wide
ranging piece that we're looking at it
covers everything from
microchipping of cats dealing with the
problem of puppy smuggling right through
to that ban on
live animal exports it's a huge area i
know one of the one of the key
points is you you it's now recognized or
will be recognized officially in law
that animals are sentient
well we those who are pet lovers
we knew that already didn't we yes um
we've always known that indeed
since we first introduced animal welfare
legislation as
long ago as 1822 obviously it recognized
that
what the bill on animal sentience
actually does though is we all know that
animals are sentient but
it gives a role to a new animal
sentience committee to
scrutinize government policy in this
area
changes to policy we make policies we
ought to maybe consider
and it puts it on a statutory footing to
give us advice on these matters so that
we can have a
constant trajectory of improving animal
welfare look can i finally ask you about
um
david cameron and and these the green
sill texts i know you used to work very
closely
with mr cameron um the texts were sort
of all published yesterday you must have
read
them surely a bit cringe-worthy aren't
they well look i've seen
uh some of them and obviously the prime
minister set up
uh the beardman review to look at all of
this
to look at this incident and in
particular in the context of the green
sill uh
the green cell episode um but i think
you also have to step back from this and
say
well the prime minister yes a former
prime minister david cameron did
approach ministers did lobby on behalf
of this company
but they didn't do him any special
favors you know some of them looked at
this again
in the end they came back and said uh no
can do
when we can't help you uh you don't fit
the criteria and the business went bust
so on the on the face of it nobody did
any special favors for david cameron
he approached them but he was ultimately
unsuccessful okay minister good to talk
to you this morning thank you
now some breaking news in the last
couple of minutes you can probably see
it at the bottom of your screen the
latest gdp
figures are out let's talk to our
correspondent
paul kelsey what did they tell us paul
uh yeah morning stephen they tell us
that the economy in the first quarter
of this year shrank by 1.5
leaving the economy as a whole 8.7
still smaller than it was pre-pandemic
levels of course we spent
the first quarter of this year and
beyond in that
deep lockdown so no surprise at the
economy
should have shrunk in that time it
didn't shrink as much as it did
in the first lockdown which is signs
that would become a bit more resilient
and business has become a little bit
better at coping and we as consumers
have become better at coping with it and
the glimmer of hope in these numbers
from the ons that have come this morning
is that the economy actually grew in
march by 2.1 percent and that's
something i'm sure the chance of the
checker rishi sunak will be talking
about this morning he's here
i'm here with him at a brewery in east
london where he's going to be telling us
how
he's going to organize the recovery from
this there's been
a initial response from the chancellor
he said despite a difficult start to
this year
economic growth in march is a promising
sign
of things to come he goes on to talk
about how the government's plan
for jobs is working he's confident it
will
keep unemployment below forecast levels
and he will continue
to do to take all the steps necessary to
support
our recovery exactly what those steps
might be as we move
out of restrictions certainly on monday
when people will be
able to come to places like this and go
inside and have a drink for the first
time
in months will be interesting we look to
hear if there's any plans for any
stimulus to try and get us spending
again or whether he's
going to rely on us being confident in
the vaccine programme
to move on we'll be hearing from the
chancellor in the next hour as i say
he'll be clinging to that
glimmer of positive news that the
economy grew
in the last month although it's down for
the first quarter of the year one and a
half percent
okay paul thank you we'll sort of come
for you
this morning labor says there should
have been more emphasis on what they
call
good jobs in the queen's speech we'll be
joined by the shadow business and energy
secretary ed miliband
at five past eight
rose west's former solicitor joins us at
8 20 this morning after police in
gloucester begin
searching a cafe over a link to a girl
feared to have been murdered
by her husband
[Music]
the government revealed in yesterday's
queen's speech that it wants to ban
junk food adverts online and on tv
before nine o'clock we'll talk about
that
half past eight this morning
now we've been investigating the current
coveted hot spots in the uk
research by sky news shows a number of
coronavirus cases
is continuing to rise in 28 local
authorities across the uk
22 areas of england have double the
average
infection rate well that's a look at
some of the details the highest case is
in heinbern where almost 200 infections
were recorded per 100 000 people
as the case rate shot up by more than
200
in bolton 158.9 cases were recorded
per 100 000 people a similar number of
cases recorded
in selby while dairy city and strabane
had
uh 158.6 well the shadow health
secretary
jonathan ashworth pointed to some of the
factors that may be
behind the rise part of this is because
of
uh the lack of sick pay if you're on low
paid work a zero hours contract
you cannot take time off work to isolate
your yourselves if you're ill
or if you've been in contact with
someone who was ill that has been the
biggest failure of this pandemic
failing to offer people decent sick pain
support to stay at home we've also got
to look at
how we're rolling out vaccinations some
parts of the country have better
vaccination rates
than other parts let's talk to our
reporter hanisha sethi and it's
interesting george uses saying just a
a couple of minutes ago that you know
the the government will not
rule out adding local restrictions to
these areas if necessary
exactly and that's quite worrying
actually for people in that
area but it's quite an interesting
picture if we look at that overall
because on the whole
case rates of coronavirus in the uk have
remained
relatively low on our low on average
there are about 40 cases per 100
000 but there are these pockets of areas
throughout the uk
where cases have simply spiked and sky
news
has been looking at the data and we're
going to show you a graph of
two particular areas of concern one is
hindburn
in lancashire and it's seen over a 200
percent rise
in cases the case rate there is almost
200
per 100 000 and in bolton just northwest
of manchester
that's seen an infection rate of 160
cases
per 100 000 so both those areas are well
above
the national average and you might think
that that's actually to do with more
tests being conducted but this simply
isn't accurate the number of tests
has actually been quite stable this is
the positivity rate that's risen
both these locations as we can see on
the graph is seeing a five percent
positive
infection rate and the world health
organization is saying that for the
virus to be under control
the proportions of positive tests should
be less
than five percent but let's put that
into perspective because the rates we
were seeing on the graph
back in november were positive rates of
20 percent
so at the moment we're well below that
but this is something that
local authorities will be keeping an eye
on andy burnham
the mayor of greater manchester believes
that the spike might actually
be to do with international travel but
we do have to be mindful of these
figures as
restrictions will be easing from monday
next week but on the whole though
looking at the uk data it is looking a
much better picture
okay hannah thank you
a nine-year-old boy has died in
blackpool after reportedly being struck
by
lightning while playing football it
happened during a private coaching
session
on a playing field in common edge road
in blackpool on tuesday evening when a
thunderstorm
hit the town lancashire police say he
was taken to hospital
but did not survive
police will today continue their search
of a cafe in gloucester after reports a
woman feared to have been murdered by
serial killer fred west
may have been buried there mary bastone
was 15 when she disappeared in 1968.
fred west was said to be a regular
customer when the teenager
worked at the cafe the foreign secretary
is expected to reveal that 80 schools
and colleges have come under
serious cyber attack in a speech later
dominic raab will warn britain
must be better protected against hostile
states
and criminal gangs more than a thousand
petrol stations in the eastern united
states have
run out of fuel apparently there's been
panic buying in parts of the country
after a major pipeline was closed down
by a cyber attack
last week the search for a
nine-month-old tiger is continuing in
texas after its owner was
arrested in connection with a murder
investigation
the big cat was most recently seen after
a standoff with an armed off-duty police
officer
lawyers for 26-year-old victor hugo
cuevas
says they can't confirm that he
is the owner now female artists
dominated last night's brit awards as
the event marks something like a return
to normal life
an audience of a few thousand people who
didn't have to social distance or little
mix and jualipa
steal the show our arts and
entertainment correspondent
lucy cotter reports
at this year's brit awards the real
winner was the live music industry as it
took
one step closer to getting back to
normal
this was the first major indoor live
music event since the start of the
pandemic
4 000 people under one roof with no
masks and no social distancing
[Applause]
part of the government's pilot scheme
made possible
by covert tests for everyone
and for the stars being back on the red
carpet was a prize in itself
we haven't been on stage with an actual
audience for like for me like over a
year and a half so
yeah i think i might have to hold a
couple tears back tonight
the last live show i did i did my first
headline show and it was 200 people in a
room and now i'm here in the o2 so it's
yeah terrifying little mix
the other big winner of the night was
women after last year's awards were
heavily criticized for being male
dominated
with little mix becoming the first
female act ever to win best group
it's not easy being a female in the uk
pop industry we've seen the white male
dominance
misogyny sexism and lack of diversity
so this award isn't just for us it's for
the spice girls
sugar babes all saints kills it out
all of the incredible incredible female
buns
this one's for you
and best album went to jeweleeper who
also got best female solo artist
and gave a shout out to the two and a
half thousand key workers in the
audience
there's a massive disparity between
gratitude and respect
for frontline workers because it's very
good
to clap for them but we need to pay them
give a massive massive round of applause
and give boris a message
that we all support a fair pay rise for
our
front line thank you so much
[Music]
so while other awards ceremonies this
year bombed the brits has managed to
pull off an
important test event pull in the big
names and give us a taste of what we've
all been missing
lucy gotta sky news
after that i feel positively
underdressed i don't know about you joe
wheeler
we could do with a few more sparkles
couldn't we this morning
well if you just told me i i would have
dressed accordingly and it would have
been fine
but uh in terms of being underdressed
maybe it's probably best to dress for
the weather today
um temperatures reaching around 18
degrees celsius and for most it's a
frost-free morning once again
but the trend is downhill i'm afraid as
we go towards the weekend
let's take a look at the weather details
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
hello there good morning to you well
over the next few days we're going to
keep low pressure close by and that's
just generating these showers
sometimes showers sometimes longer
spells of rain and certainly for central
southern parts of the country
and wales we will see some more
persistent rain through the course of
the day
but for many of us this morning breaking
we're waking up to some bright skies
more in the way of cloud over northern
parts of scotland we already have quite
a raft of showers
in the north and the west elsewhere some
sunshine and certainly where we do have
the sunshine 17 18 degrees celsius
fairly likely mid teens elsewhere it's
through the afternoon that we start to
see this area of low pressure tracking
its way through the channel
and bringing some wet weather through
those central southern areas and then
all of that pushing its way
northwestwards
back into wales now i mentioned about
the showers they could be heavy they
could be slow moving
once again there could be some hail
mixed in some thunder and lightning as
well
and those very volatile showers are most
likely over parts of northern ireland
also northern parts of england
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
joe thank you still to come this morning
as research by sky news shows
rising levels of coronavirus in 28 local
areas of the uk we'll talk to the leader
of barnsley council
just a couple of minutes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i witnessed how the catalan fight for
independence split families
it was from this chamber the carlos
putimon declared independence
in october
i come here because i want to show other
people what happened
i'm michelle clifford and i'm sky's
europe correspondent
it's not the aim of the smugglers to
actually get people to uk shores
but simply into british waters
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
there are real concerns here now about
whether the health system
will be able to cope president macron
has spoken in defense of freedom of
expression
saying france won't give up its
caricatures and drawings
made by people who dare to challenge
afternoon mr barnier
how are you i have no time for any
[Music]
politics
anger about wider social and economic
problems in this nation
we are on the verge of fascism and we
have a country to say
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well let's get a little bit more on one
of our top stories this morning
researched by sky news showing the
number of coronavirus cases
is continuing to rise in 28 local
authorities
across the uk well one of those is
barnsley and sir stephen houghton is the
barnsley council leader and joins us now
it's good to see you sir stephen why do
you think
that the infection rate is increasing in
barnsley
uh well good morning um i i think the
infection rates
um are still relatively low compared to
where they were
a number of months ago but obviously
we're concerned that we're not
following the national trend and i think
the reasons for that are already well
documented first of all
we've got communities with relatively
poor health
and that makes them susceptible to the
disease and also poor outcomes from the
disease
we have and that deprivation that drives
that poor health also
drives mutual dependency in families so
we get mixing
at times when we really didn't need it
but one of the biggest reasons i think
is as people return to work
um we have large employers we don't have
much homework
and clearly when you get into large
institutions there's a danger that the
virus will spread
so those reasons have been around for a
while and as the restrictions come off
obviously
they make us more susceptible to the
disease increasing
yeah which must raise concerns about
next monday onwards where obviously
people can go into restaurants go
inside of pubs and bars and what have
you i mean
is there anything that you can do as a
council to try and slow things down
well the first thing is obviously we're
looking at our messaging for next week
because we want people to realize uh the
disease is still out there
it's not all over uh the disease is
still there
we've got to be careful and so
strengthening the communications again
is going to be really important
but what we've also asked the government
is to look at these places with high
rates of infection
to see if we can roll out the vaccine
even quicker
because we know the vaccines made a real
difference not just in terms of keeping
people safe but in stopping the spread
of the disease
so if we can get to some of those
younger age groups because it is largely
now
in those younger age groups where we're
seeing the infections
so getting getting the vaccine to those
people getting them
vaccinated as quickly as possible we
think we can start to bring those
numbers down
and obviously the concerns we have for
next week and beyond
we can allow those as quickly as
possible i mean the word from that we've
just spoken to george eustis
seems to be no that they're not going to
do that
on the advice of the the committee on on
vaccinations saying
you know that the best approach is just
to continue the rollout but what he
didn't rule out was the possibility of
perhaps some local restrictions being
applied now that isn't
the ideal solution of course but is it
one you'd be willing to accept if
necessary
well we've got to do all we can to
tackle the disease and if that's the
solution we're given then clearly
we we're not going to have any other
options to put into play
um the government have said to us so far
that
that is unlikely at this stage further
restrictions
i think what the government's really
worrying about are the emergence of new
variants and clearly if that happens
then we would expect
restrictions to come back into force all
i can do
is to say to the government we know what
works is the vaccine
and whilst you know um i understand
a broad rollout is the preferred option
when we've covered most of the older age
groups when we've covered
the vast majority of vulnerable people
then i think we've
got to start and think about where we
can be a bit more
uh pointed in terms of where we go with
a vaccine
because we don't want to see further
outbreaks and we certainly don't want to
see
new variants coming from those outbreaks
so we'll keep the pressure on the
government
yes to get to vaccine to as many people
as possible across the country
but just maybe just to think about where
we can be
most effective with it uh in terms of
the vaccine rollout in barnes i mean
where are you in terms of
of the take up amongst those age groups
that are currently eligible i mean are
you seeing people really wanting to
to get involved in this program
i mean the vaccine imbalances so far has
been a success story um
older age groups the vast majority now
you know uh it's it's something like 96
97 percent have
have been completed and we're now
working our way down the injury
and the age range so very little
resistance
um to getting a vaccine which is really
good and the nhs
working with the council have done a
fantastic job in getting vaccines
available and getting them out there
and people have responded very well but
as i say it's getting to those younger
age groups we need to do as quickly as
possible now
because that's where we're seeing the
infections rise okay
so stephen horton good to talk to you
this morning thank you
thank you uh well the breaking news this
morning that's
official figures showing the uk economy
shrank by one and a half percent in the
first quarter of this year but there are
some signs
of a bounce back in march well let's
talk to
henry morrison the director of the
northern powerhouse partnership
who joins us now good to see you this
morning look in terms of the
of the bounce back how encouraged are
you by that
i think the figures in march are welcome
but remember gdp is a measure not just
the private sector activities so those
figures you're seeing for march
largely recognize the reopening of
schools my wider concern stephen is
we're still
8.7 down in terms of lost output from
where we were in the last quarter of
2019
and that also doesn't take into account
the fact we would have liked to see
some gdp growth in that period so the
economy is significantly further behind
where it otherwise would have been and i
think
when you see the chancellor of us today
out in the media i think we'll be hoping
to see
not just on your channel but across
across the media that there is a strong
plan from the government to continue to
support the economy
and also to think about the recovery
because there are many people who have
lost their jobs in this crisis
we need to get them retrained these get
them into other jobs and there is a huge
role for the private sector to play
there but there's also role for the
government
to ensure that on big projects on areas
like hs2 and northern power israel the
big decisions coming in the next few
weeks
but we don't see cutbacks the treasury
wanting to to move back
because the risk of that is it could
obviously affect confidence in the
market
i i mean obviously the the retraining
issue
the government may argue some of that
was addressed in the queen's speech
yesterday with looking further at
adult education and what have you but
in in terms of direct moves that can be
made on the economy then it's more about
what just making sure that that you know
the um
sort of capital investment if you like
continues is is
that is that the main focus of your
argument
i think we need to see long-term
strategic choices to improve
productivity
and many of that the sort of spending
decisions that will do that
will obviously have the benefit of
creating jobs in the short term you've
also got a huge role for our metro
mayors to play so
they themselves could be given more
borrowing powers to invest in shovel
ready projects
because although whitehall can get
people back to work through investing in
projects from the center they can also
give freedoms to people like andy
burnham
to those like ben houchen up and teeside
to spend money as well because
we do need to see that all the
government's funding in this period is
being well used
on long-term strategic investments but
that also has the benefit of short-term
job creation
and if the treasury holds back wants to
wait and see how the economy pans out
it may actually make the crisis worse
there is going to be some instability in
the end of this year when the
furlough schemes are removed what we
need to see is the government's
long-term investment in leveling up
really paying dividends in that period
and not being left till later in the
parliament
when the short-term demand issues will
have gone and the benefit of doing that
spending now will have been lost
but look is there a danger then in your
view that this the two percent growth
that we've seen i know it's all relative
but the two percent growth we've seen in
march it's very important that is in
your view that we don't rest on our
laurels with that that has to just be
the the initial step to pushing this
harder and harder
i think as i said the challenge with
that march figure is that monthly
figures are very volatile
and that largely isn't private sector
rebounding what you're actually seeing
is
is schools reopening because that's
counted in those gdp figures
so i don't think that the march figures
actually give you enough to be really
genuinely confident
that we're seeing things getting better
of course it's great the schools are
reopened
but it doesn't mean private sector
activity is back to normal and in our
big cities in particular
down in london actually but in our other
large cities here in the north
manchester leads newcastle
the hospitality economy places like
liverpool is really important actually
to liverpool
so if you don't see support for the
wider economy in those city regions
then those places that have driven the
economy of this country the last few
years will be held back obviously london
usually recovers better from recessions
but across all our city regions
we need to trust those places that also
all have metro mayors to lead their own
recovery
and that's why our chair george
osborne's been really clear why others
not just myself have been making the
case to the chancellor to trust
local mayors with more borrowing powers
that's something that can be done now
actually it's all investments that will
be paid back that will
generate revenue so it's not about the
government being worse off it's about
making strategic investments now
or pay back in the long term but it but
in in terms of of
of seeing what is going to happen and
having a positive outlook i mean the
fact that as you say there's a
there's an awful awful lot of focus on
things like bars restaurants hospitality
and i mean those are things which are
really going to start opening up from
next monday that's going to make a huge
difference isn't it
of course it's good to see those areas
coming back we have to remember we did
have
relatively high levels of employment in
many sort of left-hand places
for the crisis we also have the
challenge of people who
are stuck in lower-wage jobs but
actually want to get into higher skilled
jobs
and the wider challenge in our economy
that i think has been brought to the
fore is actually
been a productivity crisis before
covered
so what we can't do is ignore the
structural economic issues the fact
we've got a significant
north-south divide in productivity terms
and that's why those kind of big
projects i mentioned as well as
short-term reforms that the better bus
system that andy burnham has been
talking about
that will improve productivity we also
need to see those longer-term projects
because otherwise we're recovering to
the world we were in before
and the challenge i think stephen is
that that economy wasn't wasn't working
for everyone we need an economy
after the crisis that works the whole
country okay henry really good to talk
to you this morning thank you well
some concerns there but we have just
heard really a positive message
from the chancellor rishi sunak he's
just said this
well i think actually today's figures
show that our
economy is clearly getting back on track
and crucially
that our plan for jobs is working now of
course
many businesses and families are still
facing tough times and that's why
our support is continuing
well political correspondent joe pike is
here support continuing as
henry murrayson was saying there they
actually want to see more of it
yeah indeed and richard tunic now has
perhaps far more
flexibility with these gdp figures with
the
bank of england upgrading their growth
forecast for rest this year which they
did
last week it's important because we know
the government spent around
300 billion pounds on the covered
pandemic
and he looked um quite limited in what
he could do
as chancellor what he could spend money
on but now he does have flexibility
and looking ahead to the next election
that is important it suggests that
uh tax hikes can perhaps be avoided he
has perhaps 20 billion pounds
to play with according to one economist
and there are some key decisions coming
up he has remember uh
extended that universal credit uplift of
20
pounds a week by six months how long
will
that last for he'll be under pressure
certainly from the labour party to
continue it
and perhaps steven he now has a room to
do so
but it will be uh it'll be interesting
to see what he does some key choices to
make but he has
perhaps now that flexibility if this um
this sort of uh
boom continues and the economy restarts
in such a positive way as these stats
today suggest
okay joe thank you now it has been one
of the most
violent nights in recent history in the
middle east at least 35
palestinians and three israelis have
been killed and amongst those
palestinian deaths actually
quite a number of children as we
understand it well let's talk to layla
moran
who's a lib down spokesperson for
foreign affairs and international
development and
who also has family who live in the west
bank good to see you this morning look
clearly this is a hugely concerning
situation with this real escalation in
violence
absolutely and you know we wake up this
morning
to as you say the death toll rising the
number of injured
is also rising on the palestinian side
over 700
i understand now um and we've lost
children
uh some as young as one year old i mean
it's really a tragic situation
but what's even worse is it does look
like it's getting
worse the un special envoy uh has said
that
it's moving towards at war and
this comes off the back of not just
further air strikes
in gaza but also for the first time
since 1966 the israeli government has
called a state of emergency in the city
of lod
this is not good um so today in
parliament
i've called an urgent question the
speaker has granted
uh that so that we can discuss it and
what i'll be calling on
uh for the government to do is to engage
with our international partners
to ensure de-escalation um because
unless
forgive me for jumping in forgive me for
jumping in
how does the government do that because
as we know from this hugely volatile
situation
over the decades that is that that is
the big question how you de-escalate
this situation who do you apply the
pressure to
well in the first instance uh this has
to be done through the united nations as
imperfect as it is
uh it is the best forum for this and
should there be draft resolutions that
come forward historically britain
has been quite lukewarm towards these
kinds of resolutions we actually need
them to be quite robust
at the moment but there are other things
that britain can also do
first of all it's worth remarking that
this started
over if they happen potentially illegal
evictions in an area
called sheikh sharach this comes off the
back
of other illegal activity in the eyes of
international law
demolitions and also increased
settlements that the israeli government
has allowed to happen and the
international community
so far whilst they have condemned it
haven't really done anything about it at
all
a u.n resolution i understand is
potentially being drafted
and i would encourage the government to
stand by it
regardless of what america may or may
not do actually what we need now
is the full force of the international
community to say
this has to stop to encourage a
ceasefire and it's not just the israeli
government it's also hamas
who need to step back the escalation of
the rocket fire towards tel aviv
is not helpful we need people to put
down
their arms to stop killing innocent
civilians to stop killing children
and to get back around the negotiation
table and critical to all of this
is that peace negotiation is allowing
the palestinians to be able to hold
elections they were put off because the
israeli government said that they
couldn't campaign
in east jerusalem it's not acceptable
that you have one state deciding the
political
uh future of another this is not right
so there is a lot that the international
community can do but first
we have to stop the killing i was going
to say because within all of this and
every time we talk to
to the leaders of israel or members of
the israeli defense force of course they
they come back with a clear argument you
know they're defending themselves
they're responding to
i mean what did we see in tel aviv last
night something like 150 rockets
fired towards what is the tourist
capital uh
of uh of israel i mean no wonder
there has been some sort of response
even though it
may be argued it was disproportionate
disproportionate but also you've got it
the wrong way around here because
it was the israeli authorities firstly
through
not defending the attacks on
worshippers on the most holy night of
ramadan
at the third most holy place
for the muslim community internationally
at the al-aqsa mosque
that caused this there were hundreds
injured
in that they were shooting rubber
bullets at them um
this is in it of itself disproportion
actually what the israeli authorities
there should have done
was to protect the innocent worshipers
from the extremists
and instead they escalated the situation
at that stage
and so at this point what we need to do
is to get everyone to get around the
table
to put down their arms and to stop
attributing this
who started at blame game but we also
have to remember
that when you uh have violence when
violence occurs violence begets
violence and i think it is really
critical
that the un special envoy is now saying
out loud that this could be escalating
into war
um i really don't want that no one wants
that in the end it is innocent civilians
who will be caught in the crossfire the
death toll is only rising
at the moment and it's absolutely right
i think
that us as british parliamentarians put
pressure
on our government to work with others to
do what they can to de-escalate this and
remember
britain has a historic responsibility
towards palestine
in 1970 17 the balfour declaration
made clear that it wanted uh
palestinians and the new israeli state
to live peacefully together and there
are issues with the balfour declaration
not least
uh the political rights of palestinians
but nevertheless
britain itself has an important part to
play in this and i hope
today we will hear from the minister
what they plan to do about it i mean the
problem is though
whatever pressure we put on we seem to
be talking to two
immovable sides on here yeah hamas
of course has got a a very long and very
concerning reputation doesn't seem to
to want to move that i mean the
government still headed by
binyamin netanyahu doesn't seem to want
to move we have
we have two extremes in play here don't
we
in the case of hamas yes but hamas
remember does not speak for all
palestinians
they certainly don't speak for me and my
family um
and in terms of uh the israeli
government i mean there are factions
within there that will
uh listen and and do better um and i
think there is also
certainly uh an issue right now in terms
of the coalition forming that still
needs to happen and the internal strife
that we're seeing in their government
but there is also one last trump card
that we have as a country
and that is to recognize the state of
palestine
the government has said that it wants to
do it at the right time well if the time
is not now then when
we have to appreciate that in this
escalation it is not equal
this is not an equal escalation and any
death
is one death too many on either side and
it's a tragedy
but when you have a state that is
fighting
another and that state is not recognized
by countries as important in their
history as britain
that doesn't help so actually i think
the time is now
for the government to say well israel
unless you put down your arms we are
going to recognize the state
of palestine that would matter that
would shift the dial
and it's within the gift of the british
government leonard moran good to talk to
you this morning thank you
thank you
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
hello there it's going to be another day
of sunshine and showers some of those
showers heavy
with hail thunder and lightning too
in between the showers where you get
some sunshine temperatures reaching
around 18 celsius that's 64 degrees
fahrenheit
and then later this afternoon we see
some more persistent rain working its
way into central southern england
the weather sponsored by qatar airways